Either you're a meat eater oryou're a vegetarian.
So I wondered, might there be a third solution?
And I thoughtabout it, and I came up with one.
And I've been doing it for the
last year, and it's great.
It'scalled weekday veg. The name says it all:
Nothing with a face Monday through Friday.
On the weekend,your choice.
It's structured, so it ends up
being simple to remember,
and it's okay to break ithere and there.
After all, cutting five days a week is
cutting 70 percent of your meat intake.
The program has been great, I'm healthier,
I know that I'm going to live longer,
my footprint'ssmaller,
I'm lessening pollution,
I feel better about the animals,
I'm even saving money.
What'sstopping you from giving
weekday veg a shot?
After all, if all of us
ate half as much meat,
it would be like half of us were vegetarians.